Transcription: Anaelle Fécil
Relecteur: eric vautier
Vous êtes-vous déjà senti seul?
Vous êtes-vous déjà senti pris au piège?
Moi, ça m’est arrivé.
Et je ne parle pas de maintenant.
Présenter une conférence TED,
seul, devant pleins d’inconnus,
en se disant : « Pourquoi j’ai fait ça? »
Non.
Je parle d'une longue aventure à mener.
À votre avis, quel pourcentage de gens
en France souffrent d’une maladie rare?
Eh bien, ce pourcentage, c’est 4%.
4%, en fait, c’est énorme.
Cela voudrait dire
que parmi vous, le public,
il y aurait 12 personnes
atteintes d’une de ces conditions.
Donc maintenant, regardez aux alentours.
Si ce n’est pas vous,
c’est peut-être votre voisin
ou ça concerne une personne
que vous connaissez,
comme un ami,
un membre de votre famille
ou encore une personne que vous aimez.
Et si vous, personnellement,
vous pouviez faire quelque chose?
Si vous pouviez,
avec l’aide de la science,
vous battre contre ces maladies rares,
le feriez-vous?
J’aimerais vous introduire
une de ces maladies rares
qu’on appelle
le «déficit en facteur V congénital».
Ça a l’air compliqué vu son nom,
mais c’est une maladie génétique
qui provoque chez ses patients
des saignements plus abondants
et sévères que la normale.
Elle est causée par une mutation
sur un gène appelé «F5»
qui commande une protéine,
appelée «facteur de coagulation V»,
qui est dans ce cas manquante ou presque.
Cela cause donc l’apparition
de saignements plus longs chez le patient,
parfois à la suite
de traumatismes, de chirurgie
ou lors des menstruations pour les femmes.
Et il y a eu des décès avec cette maladie,
concernant, par exemple, des nourrissons,
mais, en général,
tous les âges sont touchés.
Et même dans les cas plus modérés,
voire mineurs,
la qualité de vie du patient peut baisser
à cause des saignements fréquents
qui peuvent altérer son quotidien.
Vous vous demandez peut-être
comment je sais tout ça,
et surtout, pourquoi?
En fait, c’est beaucoup plus simple.
Je connais cette maladie
d’un niveau plus personnel.
Je connais l’expérience
de ce simple saignement de nez,
ou d’un petit accident,
qui devient très vite incontrôlable.
Parfois même, je dois rester au lit
pendant quelques jours
à cause de ces saignements
qui peuvent durer
une demi-heure, une heure, voire plus,
et qui peuvent rythmer
des semaines entières.
On pourrait alors se dire qu’il existe
un traitement pharmaceutique adapté
qui pourrait au moins
prévenir ces saignements,
mais non.
Les seuls traitements disponibles
sont en général des produits
dérivés de dons de sang
qui sont souvent inaccessibles
et qui peuvent causer
plusieurs effets secondaires.
Et pourtant, c'est une maladie génétique
qui est caractérisée depuis les années 50.
Et depuis, les innovations dans le domaine
de la biologie et de la médecine,
ont permis d’ouvrir la voie
à de nouvelles thérapies.
Alors, pourquoi cette maladie
ne peut toujours pas être traitée?
En fait,
c’est parce que deux mille personnes
sont atteintes de cette maladie sur Terre.
Deux mille.
Deux mille personnes, ce n’est pas rien,
mais ce n’est pas assez.
En termes d’étude de marché,
ce n’est pas rentable.
En termes de politique de santé,
c’est négligeable.
Et surtout, pour les chercheurs,
c’est énormément de temps,
de ressources et d’efforts consacrés,
si on veut découvrir
un nouveau traitement.
À 14 ans, donc il y a deux ans,
après un long mois
rythmé par ces saignements,
je me suis dit:
« Si personne ne peut le faire
pour l’instant, alors pourquoi pas moi ?
Pourquoi ne pas au moins proposer
une idée intéressante et rationnelle,
poser la première pierre d’un édifice
qui permettrait, peut-être un jour,
de trouver une solution? »
Alors, voici mon plan.
On va parler de quelques
détails techniques -
si vous êtes perdus, ce n’est pas grave,
je l’étais aussi au début.
En passant deux ans
à étudier l’hématologie et la biologie,
on peut s’intéresser
à une thérapie prometteuse,
c’est la thérapie par ARN messager.
Vous la connaissez peut-être
à cause des vaccins contre la COVID-19,
mais cela n’a rien à voir
avec notre sujet.
Dans notre cas,
c’est comme si on essayait
d’introduire un code dans une machine
afin qu’il exécute un objectif précis.
Le code, c’est l’ARN messager.
Et l’objectif,
c’est que le patient puisse
à nouveau avoir dans son sang
la protéine facteur V en la produisant.
On va donc combler son manque.
On va donc essayer d’insérer
l’ARN messager codant le facteur V
dans les cellules du patient,
et, puisque l’ARN messager
se dégrade assez vite dans le corps,
on l’enferme dans de très petites
structures circulaires
qu’on appelle
des « nanoparticules lipidiques ».
Ces structures vont permettre
à l’ARN messager de se libérer
dans les cellules du patient et qui vont,
avec l’aide de leur séquence,
synthétiser à nouveau
la protéine facteur V.
En général, la thérapie par ARN messager
semble intéressante,
novatrice
et efficace,
selon certains articles scientifiques.
Cependant, c’est encore une technologie
à ses balbutiements,
il faudra énormément d’études poussées
sur des animaux
et sur des humains
afin de prouver son efficacité
ainsi que sa sûreté.
Et à partir de ce moment,
on ne peut plus faire grand-chose.
J’ai mon idée, mais je ne dispose pas
des moyens financiers ou humains
pour lancer une étude scientifique.
Et si je me construisais
mon propre laboratoire?
J’avais une idée en tête qui permettrait,
si tout se passe bien,
de produire de l’ADN chez moi.
On pourrait ensuite, avec cet ADN,
fabriquer de l’ARN messager
pour ces expériences
ou tout simplement étudier
le gène de la protéine du facteur V.
Mais en premier,
il faut un espace de travail.
J’ai donc construit le mien, pour pouvoir
travailler avec des techniques de labo
dans mon garage,
entre des planches de bois
et quelques étagères,
avec, sur la table bancale,
un micro-ondes qui ne marche presque plus
et d’autres accessoires
indispensables au laboratoire,
comme une micropipette.
Ce n’est pas le labo idéal
pour quoi que ce soit,
mais on va se contenter de cela.
Dans mon cas, je voulais obtenir
en grande quantité de l’ADN du gène F5
responsable du déficit
dans le facteur V, chez moi.
Donc, de l’ADN fait maison.
Et j’ai bien essayé -
car il y avait tant de hauts
et de bas en ce périple,
que j’ai failli abandonner plusieurs fois.
En fait,
j’ai essayé de cultiver des bactéries
très utilisées en laboratoire
qu’on appelle « Escherichia coli »,
auxquelles on a injecté
de l’ADN du gène F5.
Si tout se passe bien,
les bactéries qu’on cultive se multiplient
et l’ADN qu’on introduit avec aussi.
En le purifiant, on obtient donc
de grandes quantités d’ADN
qu’on pourra ensuite utiliser
pour de futures expériences.
Et avoir assez d’ADN est vital pour
commencer n’importe quelle expérience.
Malheureusement,
rien ne s’est passé comme prévu.
Après avoir reçu une souche de bactéries
d’un chercheur,
j’ai essayé de les cultiver
en les déposant
sur une surface gélatineuse qu’on appelle
un «milieu de culture LB agar».
La première déception,
c’est de ne voir aucune bactérie
pousser après des jours d’attente.
Normalement,
si tout se passe bien, on doit avoir ça.
Mais dans mon cas,
on ne voyait rien du tout.
Et les échecs vont s'enchaîner.
Entre l’apparition de champignons
dans mes cultures
les accidents de labo et j’en passe...
ces défaites qui [me font
reprendre] ces étapes
que j’ai eu tant de mal à finir.
Avec un peu plus de patience
et de rigueur cette fois-ci,
après quelques défaites
et surtout de nombreux essais,
un jour,
presque agacé,
j’arrive enfin à voir
des bactéries apparaître.
Des colonies entières qui grandissaient,
qui se multipliaient.
Ça a marché!
Cela peut être anodin pour moi, pour vous,
mais c’est une étape qui est de base
inaccessible à un niveau.
Vous avez devant vous des bactéries
qui produisent et qui cultivent
de l’ADN au fil du temps.
On pourra ensuite, avec cet ADN,
cultiver, produire de l’ARN
pour la suite des expériences.
Voilà, c’était la première étape
de mon plan.
Elle est minime,
elle ne comprend pas grand-chose,
mais elle est achevée.
C’était la première marche
de mon escalier.
Et j’ai réussi.
Ces expériences m’ont donné
au moins l’opportunité
d’en savoir plus sur la biologie,
et surtout, comment la manipuler.
On pourra par la suite
étudier l’efficacité de ce traitement
sur des cellules
ou sur des organismes
encore plus complexes.
Mais cette fois-ci,
dans un meilleur laboratoire, je l’espère.
Il est désormais possible,
grâce aux avancées technologiques
de notre époque,
de connaître presque
tous les savoirs du monde.
N’importe qui peut donc
se lancer dans la science,
tout dépend s’il utilise son savoir
pour le bien commun.
Et j’y ai contribué,
dans mon propre cas.
J’espère que tout ce travail fait,
et surtout à venir,
permettra peut-être un jour
à ces quelques 2000 patients
d’enfin recevoir un traitement
adapté à leur condition.
Nous n’en sommes même pas
au début de cette aventure,
le risque l’échec est grand,
mais peut-être qu’un jour,
ces personnes pourront enfin
avoir une vie plus gérable,
voire sauvée.
Et croyez-moi qu’il faudra moins
de 4% de la population pour y arriver.
Il faut juste de la patience,
de la volonté
et quelques mains tendues.
Pour moi, ces mains tendues ont été
l’Association française des hémophiles.
le docteur Olivier Christophe,
de l’Inserm,
ainsi que le docteur Gavin Wright,
de l’Institut Sanger.
Et j’aimerais conclure ce TED
en les remerciant
pour leur écoute ainsi que pour leur aide.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)